sex
sent them to the er for this i needed a
consultation from my good friend dr rena
malek welcome to the channel thanks so
much for having me are you excited to
watch the show i'm so excited and i've
heard you watched a couple episodes i
watched one yeah
it looks like your penis has sustained
major trauma what is all of this
it was
like
wearing a medieval torture device is
probably not most people's idea of a
good time but this man had been
unfaithful before so this couple thought
it was necessary i've not seen a patient
who's been forced to wear one because
they've been unfaithful
yeah that's a punishment as opposed i
mean maybe they want the punishment so
like s m you gotta be open to that adult
play after lovemaking this couple went
through their bizarre ritual when she
take the key and lock them up until they
meet again the bit that hurts the parts
make it work
my favorite part
i'm the only one with the kitty or
what would happen if you were to get an
erection trapped inside of a plastic
case it would hurt it would hurt and you
could possibly damage your penis right
if the erection was bent in a different
way you could create micro tears in the
penis which over time could cause
problems with erectile function oh my
gosh my necklace the key i've lost it
you what
oh my god you're gonna break me free
brace yourself oh no
you know we do see things get stuck on
penises and
all the time uh people will use
different things as [ __ ] rings and then
they'll fall asleep they'll
they'll be intoxicated or they will have
an erection and then it gets swollen and
then it gets stuck you have to use all
sorts of different things like jiggly
saws to cut them off but not a hammer
fortunately it looks like just abrasions
and contusions there's no role here for
an ultrasound to check for hematomas i
feel like well so you can get an mri to
make sure there's no fracture but
ultimately if there's just hematomas or
you know essentially blood clots or you
know blood forming underneath the
foreskin there's really nothing you need
to do but wait for some time please just
get these things out of me okay things
get what out of you
the rocks okay the rocks
[Music]
hey
let's use these
pop rocks candy rock those the pop i was
gonna say that but then i was like
that's ridiculous
raging yeast infection here and here
they're burning okay oh it hurts there's
lots of swelling and irritation use toys
or devices aids that are used they're
meant for sexual purposes they have you
know flavored lube favorite condoms make
sure you try them on your skin before
you try them down there to make sure
you're not having an allergic reaction
or something but these some of these
things can put you at higher risk for
yeast infections like you talked about i
better put it somewhere else
i wonder what it'd feel like
down there i tell her you know this
isn't a good idea i probably shouldn't
be doing this sugar is not meant to be
in that area yeah generally speaking you
know you want to keep sticky icky things
away from the genitals good point after
the popsicle melted this couple went to
heat things up in the bedroom she was
scruming around quite a bit more than
normal so i kind of figured something
was wrong there was some tenderness or
something
so i was hoping it was just an infection
an infection that quickly is
unreasonable i really don't want to tell
the story so i was really vague with the
doctor and we were using
you know sort of a sex toy this is so
common i'll just tell you that people
never want to say exactly what they were
doing very often they were like minding
their own business or something else or
you know they make up a story because
they're super embarrassed what's the
wildest story you've ever had like now
while it's like the worst example where
it's obviously unbelievable well so
there was a guy who
was
cheating on his wife
and he came in for a penile fracture
which is where you um if you have
vigorous intercourse and you break the
penis essentially and you have to that's
a surgical emergency so he came in he
told his wife he was masturbating in the
car and that's how it happened
popsicle okay it was a popsicle that's
what we used as a sex toy
and after a while i just got numb to it
you definitely gave yourself cold
peniculitis that's a quick diagnosis
yeah called tranniculitis cold
peniculitis in my head is like kind of
like frostbite is that yeah i think so i
think that's reasonable i mean it's
basically exposure to cold that leads to
an eruption of the skin causing you know
kind of a rash-like syndrome should
clear up in a few days we'll get you
some ointment to take care of the
inflammation i'm assuming you're going
to throw some corticosteroid on that
problem
you know what we learn in med school
it's when it's dry it make it wet when
it's wet make it dry a popsicle is not a
sex toy just like how we say if you're
icing an injured area you don't apply
the ice directly to the skin because you
could damage the skin that's essentially
burning your skin with ice absolutely
which is counterintuitive right burning
with ice yeah my husband has a problem
with his private parts it's my penis
it's all red and swollen why when we
talk about our bodies we get so
uncomfortable what is what that happens
often oh i think it starts when we're
young right if your parents don't teach
you the right words for vagina and penis
you know you're like my hoo-ha my this
my you know and it becomes like an
embarrassing thing and it's part of
culture that penis
looked like a cabasa with speed bumps
these bumps on your penis are they some
kind of beads he said those are glass
beads that have been implanted in the
skin of my penis
we like his penis the way it is that's
all you need to know people have
injected many things into their penis
right there's a there's a big population
in prisons that does a lot of injecting
of fillers and actually these beads
is penis pearling i believe it's called
they um there it started in asia with
this this uh this crime syndicate i
think it's called
camera name for every year they were in
prison they would insert another pearl
they were doing it as a punishment it
was like a positive thing correct to
show like how manly they are just use a
ribbed condom exactly i think it's the
same thing right the infection could
spread and you could lose a lot more
than just the bead it could be fatal get
it out please so the procedure that we
use is we numb the area then i make a
small incision in this case over the
bead and then pop the bead out gotcha
gotcha gotcha gotcha
okay we're done you did great and then
you leave the rest of the beads in there
well if they're not infected in theory
you could leave them in there i saw a
man's genitals swollen and slightly
bluish discolored at the base of them
was this large steel ring ring on the
testicles maybe you look terrible
this is all my fault
oh hello
hi
how about a man's bringing home a new
accessory from a sex toy party be a bad
thing i don't think that's gonna fit
around me it doesn't go around just that
it goes around
everything some people get pleasure from
perineal stimulation right so when
you're tugging on it the erectile bodies
of the penis go down into the perineum
but whenever using rings you want to use
ones that are silicone that can stretch
really easily or have some sort of
release valve otherwise you'll end up in
a situation like this i can't get it off
oh my god danny i'm gonna go to the er
damn looks like the only way we're gonna
be able to get this ring off is by
cutting it off what kind of saw you you
said earlier
what's a jiggly
i never thought i'd ask that what's a
jiggly you know i don't really know what
it is we just know that's what we have
to call for okay and sometimes we have
to call the fire department if the er
doesn't have one but then they bring
that giant thing yeah this ring was
bigger and thicker than most of the
rings that i've seen before but i figure
well let me see if we can cut through
that
yeah i've used one of those before and
then i i feel like you could put like a
a piece of metal to protect yes so you
can get like a small malleable blade
from the or and put it underneath so
that it hits that we're going to need a
bigger tool
oh here we go
he called the fire department why are
they holding him like he's going to jump
hold him still okay
[Music]
i was frankly a little worried you know
could i pull this off all right here we
go ready look at that
and the ring is off
that was a scary way of doing it this
man had a close call so here's some
advice for you ladies too just because
you like it doesn't mean you should put
a ring on
she seemed to be having this fantastic
orgasm
it was as though we were still having
sex even though we had stopped for
some minutes
it's almost 8 30. the meter maids are
coming soon you're going to move your
car
it won't stop
what
are you still having an orgasm yes so i
don't know about having long orgasms
certainly usually don't last this long
but you can have persistent genital
arousal disorder which is a rare
condition that happens in mostly women
where they have persistent feelings of
arousal and the same changes that happen
in your body when you're aroused and
having orgasms like blood flow to the
area and sometimes sensitivity can
continue to occur it can be very
distressing and actually uncomfortable
it's not like a pleasurable scenario
coming in the door in a full orgasm
let's give her some dyes about
all right and run those tests so they
went to
dispensary to try and get the valium and
while they were still writing up the
paperwork i stopped that's got to be
traumatizing if the next time you have
sex you're like whoa what if that
happens again yeah and usually so with
these patients who have it persistently
not in this short period it can be like
extremely distressing and up to 54 of
people like say they'll have suicidal
ideation i mean it's really serious yeah
it got to the point where i could just
be like doing whatever watching tv
walking down the street and i could have
an orgasm out of the blue i would have
as many as 12 spontaneous prolonged
orgasms in one day at the end of the day
after a lot of research was done they
finally determined that i'm bipolar and
they had to switch me from
antidepressants to bipolar meds so i
guess this was like the mania component
of the bipolar i think it was probably
pgad or persistent dental arousal
syndrome or disorder and again they can
be treated with antipsychotics so maybe
she had other emotional symptoms as well
but i think yeah i don't think you can
make a diagnosis of bipolar disorder off
of just that one symptom right so there
have to be other things that they're not
sharing right i have a very happy sex
life
and that's a really great feeling well
that's great because i worry that by
taking medications could you hurt your
sex life could there be sexual
dysfunction as a result of the medicine
yeah so ssris have side effects of low
libido very commonly if you do develop
low libido on these medications they can
either change medications or add
medications to help with libido so if
you're suffering from that talk to your
psychiatrist or
doctor whoever's prescribing it i'm
sorry i didn't mean to hurt you baby he
gave her a look at one point which said
to me apparently there was something
more going on the vacuum hose was
attached to his penis and his left
testicles trapped inside we use vacuum
erection devices for men with erectile
dysfunction but they're a controlled
suction right so in this case you know
it's uncontrolled suction when i examine
his genital region i see swelling and
bruising and disgrutal sack could be
compromised and of course the pedis
could be suffering injury as well i
began cutting the vacuum hose with the
saw
did he need to bring this like why is
there sparks it's not metal everyone
heaves a great sigh of relief but our
celebration is short-lived it's clear
that his genitals are swollen they're
bruised they really look to be in poor
shape if you have something that's on
there for a significant period of time
yeah it's going to constrict and
constrict and it's going to cause
swelling beyond the constriction and
then it will just start getting bigger
and bigger and over time yes you can
cause blood flow to decrease to the
penis so you want to get it taken care
of as quickly as possible because of the
size of the tomato seal which is a
collection of blood it was very likely
that the circulation to the testicle was
compromised is that bad
surgical emergency immediately or else
doors open income the paramedics with
this lady you open your eyes let's get
her to this bed non-verbal
pale she's in shock she needs immediate
intervention can you tell me exactly
what happened you know my papa dying has
been really stressful on everyone this
had occurred after the death of a family
member at the wake they snuck off for
some alone
seriously what are you doing i'm
ovulating when this husband wasn't able
to perform they broke into grandpa's
prescription stash who has funerals in
their own homes
i don't know at the person who's
deceased home especially i know she's
ovulating but she's going to be
ovulating
doesn't have to happen during the
funeral and also perfectly acceptable to
not be in a sexual mood at a funeral
absolutely like i think that's a big
thing in in men's sexual health right
it's okay that you are not always ready
to perform and i think that adds so much
anxiety and so much stress for men and
women are like why can't you what i've
seen pattern wise emerge is
my female patients try to always look
physically perfect to
um their friends and family members the
male patients always try and be mentally
perfect yeah so they might not smell
great in that but they always have to be
tough and strong and aggressive what's
this
nitro paste it would open up how do they
know physiology so well that they're
like we know how nitro paste works i
don't know like let's put this on your
penis like what grandpa's heart
mentioned
gets the blood flowing right let's try
it
wow
whoa that worked better than i expected
would that work like
i didn't even know if that's like a
treatment anything that increases nitric
oxide will increase blood flow to the
penis and then cause an erection so
potentially yes do not recommend okay
okay
sam
oh my god sam what's the matter so she's
basically experiencing systemic effects
of the nitro where she's vasodilating so
much so that it's dropping her blood
pressure but i'm surprised he's not
because yeah nitro pace is meant to be
absorbed topically so why is he not
getting any symptoms that she is and
that's the last thing i remember
dude you had sex in papua's house and
uses madison at his wake that's crazy
how was this show
huge thank you to dr malek for coming
over check out her channel and if you
want to see some more tlc shows click
here as always stay happy
[Applause]
[Music]